I have this sort of weird quest that I
started in in Colorado several years ago
driving around with Corey Haims
I was talking about about the word
legacy with him and I was saying why do
we why do we use the word legacy as a
bad word should be a good word and when
I was a musician and as a musician the
idea of leaving a legacy is really
appealing
you know John Coltrane left a legacy for
example Beethoven etc so I've been
thinking about how do we create systems
that can survive longer than five years
or whatever the typical amount is and
I've been thinking and talking about
this for years I was then recruited to
become CTO at Wunderlist in Berlin three
and a half four years ago and when I
came in we had an architecture that
looked something like this
so here's my architecture diagram for
the wonderla stew system we had a circle
on the top and a cylinder on the bottom
and then some arrows and how many of you
have an architecture like this in your
system how many of you are trying to
refactor away from that architecture how
many of you are trying to refactor to
that architecture really really okay ah
so we went kind of crazy and we built
this I'm not gonna explain everything
here but it this was me with my crazy
ideas from my legacy code thing and the
stuff I've been talking about for years
I'm probably almost out of time already
aren't I no I had this point of view
coming in though I wanted to build
something that could survive and I
should remind you or tell you this is a
to-do app it's embarrassing but it
really is you see these dots here
ellipses or however you pronounce that
these represent like tens of other
services so just imagine each one of
these things as a separate service
that's really deployed separately talks
via HTTP we had 100 something
independent we still have it on hundred
something independent services to make
this thing go and they were all really
tiny we launched this thing in 2014 and
when we told our investor that we were
going to do it it wasn't the guy from
Sequoia it was someone else you could
hear him on the other line you could
almost hear him about the scream and
holding like squelching the screen
you know and finally he said please tell
me you're never going to tell me you're
rewriting this system again because he'd
been through this pain over and over
with this company I said we won't do it
I promise this is the last time if if we
don't like if you find out that we're
rewriting the system you can like
publicly shame me I will leave the
industry you can fire me from this job
that'll be it so he felt pretty good
about that because I honestly told him
like you can just embarrass me publicly
and I'll just leave in shame I'll be
done since we released this in 2014
we've rewritten almost every single
piece of code here but this has not
changed and that's the that's the great
thing so the fact that we rewrote the
code was very very good a little bit of
where I was coming from when I was
starting to think about legacy code and
how you can create systems that survive
I went through this really kind of
superficial tour through how systems
that survive work so for example you can
have a car that's older than most
software systems can be alive and you
know how is it that a car can survive
that long and kind of software system
can't but the most remarkable one to me
is I'm now 42 years old I don't do any
maintenance on myself I don't deserve to
be alive but somehow Here I am so I
started thinking a lot about this and I
first got kind of fixated on this idea
from biology and I will tell you they're
wrong like the stupid all I can
understand version because I really
don't care about science to be honest
but homeostasis is the process that an
organism biological organism goes
through that will balance itself out
basically so you have all these Marty
says I'm writing he knows science you
have all these like competing things
going on in your body and if one was
left unchecked and not balanced by
another one it would over on the system
and it would die and I thought this is
really interesting from the perspective
of systems because you know you have
like back pressure and all these
concepts for keeping systems alive under
stress I thought this was going to be
the key but I took a little detour and
just kind of the most obvious thing when
when you talk about biology with people
and the human body you learn early on in
life that you know we're not made up of
the same exact cell
that we were previously they're always
dying and it's like trillions per second
I think I mean on one body so imagine
the death happening in this room right
now it's amazing and we are everyone in
this room will die eventually by the way
this is about impermanence we'll all be
dead I'll die sooner than most of you
I'm sure
so why was what was i doing oh yeah yeah
regeneration so this is how it works
like the system of my body somehow I'm
still me and I'm walking around on the
stage and I'm telling the same stupid
jokes I've been telling for five years
but a lot of the matter here is gone and
it's replenished and that happens by the
fact that you know my body can do that
and it's it's a natural necessary part
of living because you know the
individual cells you wouldn't want to
try and build a thing like me where the
cells just survive forever that's kind
of unrealistic so I started thinking
about this in terms of software and I
got really sort of fixated on the
concept of everything being tiny as did
Fred George when he came up with the
concept of micro seviche micro services
for those of you who still don't speak
the language so tiny components you know
you think about it if you're looking at
code yeah when you when you come across
a huge long thing like the pseudocode
with all of the the comments in it from
earlier sometimes it takes some time to
figure it out because it's really
complicated but when you come across
something really tiny you understand it
immediately usually unless it's you know
obfuscated on purpose so there's
something really nice about small things
and I got so into it that I I did this
whole talk it was a code mash in in
London a few years ago which is an
excellent conference and it was in front
of all these people that are way smarter
than I am just saying like tiny keeping
things tiny is the secret to great
software to teams that work well to
projects that work well etcetera and
there probably is a lot of stuff that's
truth that's true there and some of the
things that stood out there is like
think about some of these phrases and
see they don't roll off the tongue very
well like massive elite team
huge efficient codebase long successful
project in normal enormous agile company
these days if you put a capital A on
that it actually does sort of fit
doesn't it I also did all sorts of
superficial research for this one like I
did with the the biology stuff and I
found all these references to proof of
course you can prove anything if you
just research it but all these
references to proof that humans are are
better at dealing with small amounts of
information and it just makes sense you
know so this one is the the magic number
7 plus or minus 2 I think it is ok good
well plus or minus 2 it's about the
human capacity to retain information and
then you start learning about chunking
in different ways that humans take small
amounts of stuff and when they get too
big they could convert it into small
amounts of stuff and coarser grained
chunks there's also like Dunbar's number
if you've ever read the tipping point
about sizes of teens at a certain size
where you can't really actually grasp
and maintain connections with people
anymore so there's a cohesion thing all
of this stuff though it leads to I
skipped a slide somehow this is amazing
ok it leads to the ability to do some
other stuff and this is what I started
figuring out after I gave this talk so
I'm kind of embarrassed you know because
I went on the stage and I said this is
it guys I'm done I figured it out but it
actually if you think about it like tiny
components one of the best things about
say a tiny method when you look at or a
tiny microservice is it allows you to
consider replacing it like you can
change it you can understand it really
quickly but even if you can't if it's
small enough and it's named well enough
and it's decoupled well enough which
micro-services tend to be you can throw
it away and just restart if you have to
so also at wunderlist
in in the attempt to to do this like
biology kind of thing we were using chef
I think yeah chef when I started so
anyway any of you do that sort of stuff
chef puppet
op stuff you know the idea behind that
is that you have a system you need to
keep it in a like understood state the
consistent state and it runs for a long
time like I used to be a system
administrator and the 90s I remember
having systems that were up for two
years and being really proud of that now
I realize though that's terrifying
like if a system is up for two years
it's very difficult to know actually how
to recreate it what the state might be
so tools like chef and puppet they're
obsolete of course but you know they're
they're all about maintaining a system
that can stay alive for a long time what
we figured out is you should just throw
away the systems that's the best way to
do it don't change the systems because
then you get rid of all of the issues of
these like weird unchangeable scary
things throw them away and start over
so we we establish this beautiful
immutable infrastructure system where if
you wanted to upgrade anything on a
given server and of course they're not
physical servers anymore they're images
or VMs then you would throw away the
entire thing and just rebuild a new one
or replace it the beautiful thing there
is that you you know exactly what's
there you know you can recreate it
you're doing it all the time so the
thing is changing which proves its
ability to change and it makes you have
a system that is able to change and so
this has worked out very well for us
then we started thinking about it in a
little bit more radical way of course
you know the several years ago we were
doing that that was already pretty
strange the more radical thing was how
do you change your software well maybe
you should just plan to throw it away
and this is where I start talking about
the code fetish thing you know at
Microsoft we have code that's 20 years
old and it's reusable let's share it all
over the place and people will both love
it and feel tied to it so and if you've
worked in a big company you probably
know this thing where you have these
reusable libraries and we're kind of
stuck to what they can do and they
follow you around they give you stuff
but you're stuck so we started saying
well let's just plan to throw our
software away so when we write it
there's a little bit less stress we can
also try out new things because there's
less stress about trying out the new
things and not only can we throw them
away throw away the pieces of code but
we
should because you know think about it
if you need to be able to change your
software that is the thing that we all
sort of struggle with that's the only
reason we have conferences and talk
about code maintainability if you never
had to change it who cares but if you
need to be able to change it if you do
it all the time and you plan to do it
then it becomes easy throw stuff away so
here we go talking about system versus
code again the mutability of the system
is enhanced by the immutability of its
components and so what I mean here is if
I need to be able to change an entire
app system or software system if I
declare that you cannot change anything
inside a component you can only replace
it then it makes the entire thing easier
to understand and easier to actually
change so this is sort of a core thing
then that we figure it out together on
our to-do app and you know as a reminder
the point here is that the system is the
thing we care about so I didn't lie to
our investor we wrote rewrote all these
pieces of code we did not rewrite the
system and still exists and I forgot to
mention the reason we did that I think
it was within a year we rewrote 80% of
the code and there was no project where
someone said I'm going to now work on
rewriting a piece of code there was
nothing in a backlog it was just
maintenance work so while I do this
feature change I'm just gonna replace
the whole thing why do I do that one
because it's healthy to be able to
change code so I'm gonna prove I can to
the more important one we were able to
go from let's say 30 servers running a
ruby process to three servers running a
scholar process because we had to
replace the toy people were using and we
had to use a real language for it
sorry rubyists I love Ruby I'm just
joking so where was I ah yes speaking of
not being on Ruby we in the original
version of this picture back here I
shouldn't be jumping back it's really
not worth it but the original version of
this pretty much everything was Ruby
except some things that just obviously
wouldn't scale and work with Ruby
without way too much work
and in the new version there is still
Ruby in here for some things that were
just the pain in the ass to change we
didn't want to but now it's like you
know as I said there are hundreds of
services up here when Sarah showed a
slide with all these different languages
on it earlier we have all of them
actually and my rule for the team is you
can use any language you want even if
you're an intern
I don't care and for production like
hopefully you can deploy it very soon to
production that it has to fit with our
deployment system our metric system a
few other things but you know just a
small rule set and the reason I wanted
to do that is because I actually wanted
this radically heterogeneous codebase
because I've been an environment so many
times over the years where you're on a
specific version of the JVM or of Java
or of dotnet or of Ruby or rails or
whatever and you get scared you get
stuck or you're on a specific platform
everyone on the team only knows that
platform like my team only knew Ruby
when I came and chuckled when I talked
about doing something other than Ruby
when you're on a specific platform or
language and you're stuck there you
can't change the team and that's bad so
I wanted to just fix this from the
beginning and say there is no such thing
on any given day someone who would work
on our back-end might work in five or
six different languages just to get
their normal job done without trying to
which means switching from Haskell to
closure to Ruby to go to JavaScript etc
rust the beautiful thing about that
though is if the Ruby VM or runtime gets
upgraded and we need to roll out a fix
we're not afraid to do that sort of
thing because we do that all the time
everything is already different if we
want to try a new language trivial we do
it all the time
so you just try it there's no no big
deal if it doesn't work the things are
really tiny which is the benefit of
micro services so anyone could just read
it it like if you don't know Haskell and
you're on call and my Haskell service is
messed up rewrite an elixir and deploy
it that's your fix fine
but serious like we've done this quite a
bit by the way I just came from Berlin
so I'm asleep in my brain right now but
my mouth is going and another rule that
I had for the team is no shared code and
this is the one really freaks people out
because sometimes when I talk about the
service based approach they say well
what do you do about shared code we
don't allow shared code even if we're in
the same language like one of the
benefits of being heterogeneous is it's
hard to have shared code because shared
code creates coupling I don't want that
shared code is also permanent code sort
of by definition because if I create a
library and distribute it to a bunch of
services now it's like really hard to
change I don't want that so we would do
shared services and we did some things
to make that not as stupid as it sounds
but even like logging things like that
we didn't do shared code we did shared
services all running on localhost on the
Box irrelevant as you all do docker now
or whatever but then the way the parts
of the system worked we thought really
hard about this and we thought like we
could do thrift or whatever the modern
thing is that people would do what is it
called someone would know I'm old and I
would say thrift we just have HTTP and
JSON that's how our service is interact
even though we have hundreds of services
for this to do app it's dumb and it's
inefficient you can read it on the wire
you know if you can get into the SSL
traffic of course but you know you can
totally understand as Dave was talking
about exactly what's happening on these
services if you can somehow see them and
since the system is the asset we thought
if you have an obfuscated language that
you can't understand for the way all the
pieces talk then you're screwing up the
system and you're making it hard to
understand so it was more important to
me that the system was easy to
understand than efficient now the thing
is this system actually ended up being
way more efficient than anything we
built before even in a monolith but
that's for another talk so the goal of
all this though was decoupling that's
what we were focused on and yeah we were
just making it to do app but man we
created this big crazy thing
mic feathers spoke at railsconf about
five or six years ago and he this is a
paraphrase but he showed this long java
method and it was a it was a keynote and
the first thing he did was bring up a
java method at railsconf which was funny
and he asked the audience who here
thinks this is good code and it was you
know it looked terrible it was just like
ifs and lots of indention and/or
indentation and it was terrible and no
one thought it was good code then he
said what if I told you that this code
was created and it was committed once
it's been in production for five years
and it works perfectly it's never been
changed now is it good code you're
looking this terrible piece of [ __ ] code
and everyone's saying yeah it's good
code isn't it like you didn't have to
change it and Mike's all into analyzing
source code history and trying to figure
out you know a lot of interesting stuff
about code metrics versus churn and it
was a really great point that made me
think a lot and for a while I carried
this around and repeated it because I
think I've always looked for an excuse
for code to be bad and for that to be ok
I don't know but but recently I've had
an experience that reminded me that he's
not quite right and the experience was
last week we had this hellish outage and
the system that was the hardest to
change in our big collection of dots was
my Haskell service and the reason is
it's the best code we have it's perfect
it performs better than anything else it
has never had to be changed because
Haskell if you write Haskell and it
compiles it works that's just how it
works
I'm only partially joking there Haskell
is an amazing thing but it's funny
because we were so proud of this thing
but the fact that we had never changed
it even though we didn't need to change
it made it a liability and it bit us and
I spent all day last Saturday in my
hotel in Berlin fixing a problem that
was caused by the fact that this Haskell
code had never had to be changed so even
there when your code is great perfect
things change around it that's the scary
thing so you really do have to keep
changing things you have to keep
deploying servers even though you don't
need to you have to keep rewriting code
to make sure that like your assumptions
were right and the right libraries and
dependencies were right or may
you really could accomplish this in
another language so immutable is the
same as disposable in my world meaning
if you can't change something then you
have to be able to replace it at least
because things do change whether you
like it or not we also sort of gave up
on testing so I thought about changing
the title and direction of this talk to
heresies so here would be one of them in
the list unit tests are a design smell
so unit tests are a design smell
do not write unit tests they are design
smell instead what we do I'll tell you
why I should probably you know I'm just
going now next unit tests or design
smell like I said my brains asleep I'm
out my mouth keeps going somehow this
thing keeps getting clicked to tests
optimized for permanence they create
more coupling because there's there's
like necessarily another file you have
to change when you want to change this
and that but the idea is that when when
you're thinking about test is validation
and by the way I don't think that
test-driven development is the design
smell I think that's a really good
productive way to work but thinking of
tests is validation it just bakes all
these assumptions about your system into
a file that you run all the time so it
creates stasis so what we decided to do
was focus more on metrics in real time
and production this is also based on my
belief that we cannot avoid errors but
we need to be able to recover from
errors very quickly so mean time to
resolution versus mean time between
failure for you systems nerds so we got
really into measuring everything in real
time at a granular level from from a
technical perspective so like
performance errors those sorts of things
but even more importantly a domain
perspective what are the things that
happen in the system that we care about
from a business perspective in my case
it would be like users signing up tasks
created synchronizations happening the
stuff that proves people are really
using and getting something out of the
application and then we put alerting
around all that an
detection around all that and that's how
we know we've screwed up our code you
know we do testing of course of certain
types before we deploy but after we
deploy and we do it in small waves we
can see whoa we're screwing things up we
back it off and we can fix it and that's
really the kind of true test of the
system of what the users are
experiencing and how it impacts the
things you actually care about so I tend
to take things too far when it comes to
impermanence I mean I've already talked
about my own demise so maybe that I
already went too far there but I think
this also applies to management and
organizations you know I'm the manager
I'm the general manager of which I keep
wanting to make like dungeon Manor
Dungeon Master if it doesn't work but
I'm the general manager of Wunderlist
and I've done a couple of org change
announcements since I started
reorge and whenever you you do this
people kind of go like oh you're doing
it again why can't you figure out an
organizational structure that will work
I believe there actually isn't one and
there would never will be one ever and
the fact that organizations change means
they're healthy just like a body so
organization should also be impermanent
and all these things apply if you if you
I mean you think about the teams that
have existed for a long time they're
never the best teams they always sort of
decay or get stuck or you know they only
have a one way of doing things and they
can't update their their thinking so I
have baked into my management strategy
that when things get too comfortable and
it looks like they're gonna get stuck in
a certain structure I should change it I
will use some [ __ ] data to back that
up
this is the reason I say [ __ ] is
because this is from the Standish chaos
report which is a survey that goes out
to big enterprises talking to them about
their software projects and determining
whether the projects were successful and
a lot of people take issue with the way
they run the thing whatever I don't care
because I look at it and I think
qualitatively it's obviously true what
the results they're getting it doesn't
matter if it's like scientifically
correct here's what it looks like
successful and failed are probably
pretty clear in terms of the percentage
of projects they surveyed challenged
means significantly over time or over
budget to me that's also failure I don't
feel you know like that's even close to
success so basically most software
projects suck and fail yeah but if you
dig in a little deeper they have some
other breakdowns and there it starts to
get interesting small projects most of
them succeed and very few of them
literally fail that's pretty interesting
why don't we learn from that small verse
and then look at large geez wow I just
look at this never make the mistake
again there it is
don't do it right small projects are
impermanent projects small project teams
are impermanent teams they will build
they will create a thing they will
disband and will reform in some other
image somewhere else so this
heterogeneous thing just kind of looping
back on you know how stuff has happened
at Wunderlist people sometimes ask me
like once you let people do any kind of
language they want do other favorite
ones they sort of stick to and the
answer is yes most people don't like
changing languages six times a day I
don't know why but in our team it's like
they're agro people and then there are
like Scala and closure people and some
of it is can you tolerate the JVM and
some of it is are you like a UNIX nerd
troll that likes procedural languages
or functional brilliant person you know
and so there have there been some things
coming up from the team where they're
like you know maybe we should just
standardize on like let's have it be
Scala closure and go and eventually work
out all the other stuff if I were a
manager experimenting with my team I
would think that's pretty cool because
one of the things I wanted to avoid I
didn't want to be that manager that
tells the team you know this is these
are your standards you will do this
because then they're going to be
complaining like ah I can't I don't get
to use elixir at work and you've all
been there probably if you're a software
developer or you're just bummed because
you can't do the thing you want to do
because it's not the standard for the
company so I wanted to get rid of that I
wanted people to feel empowered and
actually be empowered and it should be a
success now that my crazy stupid idea
the team is now reaching their own
conservative grown-up conclusions that
you know maybe this is crazy but I'm
actually disappointed I've been thinking
pretty hard about it because what I
think will happen is they will make the
decision and it'll still result in the
same mess where they get stuck like
you're on the JVM you can't upgrade or
whatever you get to where you're not
used to change and you get to where
you're just a scholar shop and you can't
deal with c-sharp because well we work
at Microsoft all of a sudden
so a few closing points did I do it on
time I did microservice is just to be
very clear in case any of you are
thinking about moving to micro-services
and I said that phrase moving to mark
micro-services it is not a thing you can
move - it's not an architecture it's
just the concept of tiny stuff but think
more about why you would do it people
don't do that you do it so that you can
change things you can do it so that you
could reduce coupling maybe you do it
for fun and then it doesn't matter but
so small is not actually the goal here
healthy longevity is the goal and fun of
course and and at least in the cursory
glance that I've given the landscape
systems that survive are made of
components that can change as Martin
Fowler likes to say if it hurts do it
more often
this is a mantra I took from my extreme
programming days and apply to everything
if you need to be able to change stuff
change it all the time then it won't
hurt that bad because you'll figure out
systems for dealing with change and
finally impermanence leads to decoupling
longevity and agility now I might answer
questions and then you might clap once
awkwardly
[Laughter]
[Applause]